Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. so that's ladies and gentlemen was the theme tune for the UEFA Champions League. Very good. Very good. Top banter you get on The Rest Is History.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告内容、系列节目的抢先收听资格，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。女士们先生们，刚才那是欧洲冠军联赛的主题曲。非常棒。非常棒。在《历史的余烬》里你能听到顶级的玩笑。
Coronation theme banter. So that, of course, is Zadok the Priest by Georg Friedrich Handel. And it was written for the coronation of George II in 1727. Tom, the moment is upon us. The first coronation in Britain since 1953 will be taking place this weekend. It's a very exciting moment, actually, isn't it? It's clearly going to be a great spectacle, a great kind of patriotic moment, a national moment, a punctuation mark. And a great historical moment, I think. Because I think it is, I mean, it doesn't matter whether you are a Republican, a secularist, an atheist, whatever.
加冕典礼主题曲的玩笑。当然，那首曲子是乔治·弗里德里希·亨德尔的《萨多克祭司》（Zadok the Priest）。它是为 1727 年乔治二世的加冕典礼而写的。汤姆，时刻已经到来。自 1953 年以来英国首次加冕典礼将于本周末举行。这其实是一个非常激动人心的时刻，不是吗？这显然会是一场宏大的奇观，一个充满爱国主义色彩的伟大时刻、一个国家级的时刻、一个历史的标点符号。而且我认为，这是一个伟大的历史时刻。因为我认为，我的意思是，无论你是一个共和主义者、世俗主义者、无神论者，还是别的什么身份。
I think if you have any interest in history and ritual, I mean, this is the World Cup final, Eurovision, Song Contest final, everything all rolled into one spectacular i wrote a feature about it in the observer last sunday in which i compared it to going to a zoo and seeing a triceratops because it it is such the roots of this ritual are so fabulously ancient but actually i think i got that wrong because i think it's it's like going on safari and seeing a mammoth okay and i and i will tell you why why. So the joke is, isn't it, that all flummery and pomp and circumstances in Britain is Victorian? Yeah. Invented traditions.
我想，如果你对历史和仪式有任何兴趣，我的意思是，这就是世界杯决赛、欧洲歌唱大赛决赛，所有这一切融为一体的视觉盛宴。上周日我在《观察家报》（The Observer）上写了一篇专题文章，在文中我把它比作去动物园看三角龙，因为——这个仪式的根源实在太古老了。但实际上，我觉得我当时说错了，因为我觉得这更像去非洲草原看一头猛犸象。好吧，我会告诉你为什么。所以，笑话就在于，不是吗？英国所有的浮华、排场和礼仪其实都是维多利亚时代的产物？是的。凭空发明的传统。
Invented traditions. That's not the case with the coronation. So you can trace the order, the kind of the order of service, the liturgy back to the 10th century in a kind of continuous line. Obviously, it's evolved, it's changed, it's been kind of new versions of it. But the lineage is pretty clear. It's probably even older than that. It goes back to the age of Charlemagne, this idea that kings should go through specific rituals. These rituals themselves hark back to the later Roman Empire, back to the age of Constantine. And other rituals are drawn from
凭空发明的传统。加冕典礼可不是这样。所以你可以把加冕仪式的秩序、某种仪式程序、礼仪一直追溯到 10 世纪，呈现出一种绵延不断的脉络。当然，它已经演变、改变过，也出现过各种新版本。但它的传承谱系相当清晰。它可能比那还要古老。它可以追溯到查理曼大帝的时代，也就是“国王应该经历特定仪式”这种观念的时代。这些仪式本身可以追溯到罗马帝国晚期，追溯到君士坦丁大帝的时代。还有其他一些仪式取材于
the Old Testament. Yeah, biblical. Taking you back to kind of, you know, 1000 BC. And those rituals in turn seem to have derived ultimately from Egypt and Syria going right the way back to 3000 BC. And that's an age when mammoths were still alive. Oh, cracking. So, you know, these traditions haven't been continuously practiced, but they've always been living traditions. They've always been taken seriously by the people who use them. A comparison might be with the Olympics, the way that the Olympics were kind of brought
《旧金山圣经》（应为《旧约》）。是的，具有圣经色彩。把你带回公元前 1000 年左右的时期。而这些仪式反过来似乎最终源自公元前 3000 年左右的埃及和叙利亚。那是一个猛犸象仍然活着的时代。哦，太棒了。所以，你知道，这些传统并没有一直在不间断地实践着，但它们一直是活生生的传统。使用它们的人一直非常认真地对待它们。一个可以类比的事物是奥运会，奥运会那种被
back, you know, brought back into existence. But for that parallel to work, the modern Olympics would have to have been going on for a thousand years and more and have been reintroduced by people who actually still believed in the Greek gods. Yeah. So you're saying the sort of spiritual nature of the coronation, because it is a religious ceremony, it's a service, that has a consistency because, you know, the king, King Charles, is a very keen believer, I think. I mean, he's a man who's often talked about his relationship with faith and all this sort of stuff. So that has a consistency that the Olympic ideal does not, because the Olympic ideal now is purely secular, right? It's nothing to do with the gods. So people have always taken these rituals seriously. I mean, the question of whether people take them seriously now, of course, is a really fascinating question that we might
重新复活的方式，你知道的，被重新带回现实世界。但要让这个类比成立，现代奥运会必须已经持续了一千年甚至更久，并且是由那些实际上仍然信仰希腊神祇的人重新引入的。所以你的意思是，加冕典礼那种某种程度上的精神内核——因为它毕竟是一个宗教仪式，是一场礼拜——具有一种一致性。因为，你知道，国王，查理国王，是一个非常虔诚的信徒，我认为。我的意思是，他是一个经常谈论自己与信仰的关系以及诸如此类事情的人。所以，这种一致性是奥林匹克精神所不具备的，因为奥林匹克精神现在完全是世俗的，对吧？它与神祇毫无关系。所以人们一直非常严肃地对待这些仪式。我的意思是，人们现在是否还严肃对待它们，当然这是一个非常引人入胜的问题，我们可能会
come to at the end of these podcasts that we're going to be doing. But people have taken them seriously, and they've taken them seriously in different ways. The theological and cultural and moral underpinnings of those rituals have changed and evolved, but they've always been taken seriously. And they've been taken seriously in a way that does, I think, take us right the way back to the Bronze Age. Essentially, there is no other civic ritual that can compare for that. So you think, I mean, the Japanese monarchy dates back to the first millennium AD. The papacy obviously
在我们将要制作的这些播客的末尾探讨。但人们确实曾经严肃对待它们，而且他们以不同的方式严肃对待它们。这些仪式背后的神学、文化和道德基础已经改变和演变，但它们一直被认真对待。而且，我认为，它们被对待的方式确实把我们带回了青铜时代。本质上，没有任何其他公民仪式可以与之相比。所以你认为，我的意思是，日本皇室可以追溯到公元第一个千年。教皇职位显然
dates back to first century AD. But the ultimate roots of this go even further back. And so it's a stupefying sense in which past and present are kind of conjoined. And how you feel about that, whether you think that that, you know, whether it's insane that in the 21st century, we should be celebrating something that can ultimately trace its roots back to the Bronze Age, or whether you think that's kind of amazing will be very much down to your personal temperament. But I think purely from the point of view of seeing something that is, I mean, it's an unprecedented chance to see something that has properly ancient roots. Okay, excellent. So before you get stuck into your Bronze Age stuff, Tom,
可以追溯到公元第一世纪。但这一切的终极根源甚至还要追溯得更远。因此，过去与现在以一种令人眩晕的方式交织在一起。你对此作何感想，无论你认为在 21 世纪庆祝一个其根源最终可以追溯到青铜时代的事物是疯狂的，还是认为这某种程度上令人惊叹，这很大程度上取决于你的个人性格。但纯粹从见证某种事物的角度来看——我的意思是，这是一个前所未有的机会，能够看到真正拥有古老根源的东西。好的，太棒了。那么，在你陷入青铜时代的研究之前，汤姆，
to give people a sense of what we're doing, this is the first of a mighty trilogy, because Tom is going to be talking about the deep roots of coronation, so the Anglo-Saxons over the Confessor. Yeah, but I'll be trying to justify this claim that you can kind of trace this as a living tradition a long, long way back. The Stone of Destiny, all of these elements. In the second episode,
为了让大家对我们要做的内容有个概念，这是一部宏大三部曲的第一部，因为汤姆将要讲述加冕典礼的深厚根源，也就是盎格ルー撒克逊人（应为盎格鲁-撒克逊人）一直到忏悔者爱德华时期的历史。是的，但我会试图证明这样一种说法：你可以把这作为一个活生生的传统追溯到非常、非常久远的过去。命运之石，所有这些元素。在第二 odc（应为集，episode），
we will be doing a whistle-stop tour of some medieval coronations, but then going, really, there's some tremendous stories about Tudor and Stuart coronations. There's some absolutely fascinating stuff, a kind of window into the kind of religious and political turbulence of the early modern period, but also some excellent stories about people being sick, behaving very badly, rioting, all this stuff. And then in the third episode, we shall do coronations in the modern age. And there, there are some absolutely shambolic Hanoverian
我们将快速浏览一些中世纪的加冕典礼，但随后，真的，会有一些关于都铎王朝和斯图亚特王朝加冕典礼的精彩故事。有一些绝对引人入胜的内容，能够让我们一窥早期现代政治与宗教动荡的窗口，还有一些关于人们生病、行为极其糟糕、暴动等的精彩故事。然后，在第三集中，我们将探讨现代的加冕典礼。在那里，有一些绝对混乱的汉诺威王朝的
coronations, which I think will make some very good stories. And we should bring it right up to date by coming into the 20th century. And I think the fascinating thing, Tom, is that each of these episodes, each of these coronations rather, is a window into the sort of political, social, economic, ideological climate of a moment in England's history, isn't it? Well, preparing for these, I mean, again, it reminded me of doing the episodes we did on the Olympics and indeed the World Cups, because that was part of the fascination of those was that it wasn't just the sporting contests themselves, but it was the way that they hold a mirror up to changes in the broader world. And in a way, the continuities that you can trace back through British and English and
加冕典礼，我认为这会造就非常好的故事。我们将把时间一直推进到 20 世纪。我认为最引人入胜的地方在于，汤姆，每一个这样的集数、每一个加冕典礼，其实都是一扇窗户，让我们得以窥见英国历史上某一特定时刻的政治、社会、经济和意识形态氛围，对吧？嗯，在准备这些内容时，我的意思是，这再次让我想起了我们之前做的关于奥运会以及世界杯的节目，因为这些节目的迷人之处有一部分就在于，它们不仅关乎体育竞赛本身，还关乎它们如何像一面镜子一样映照出广阔世界的变迁。在某种程度上，你可以通过英国、英格兰以及
indeed Scottish history serve that role for the histories of these islands. I mean, it's really fascinating. So let's start by looking at some aspects of the coronation, Tom. So you want to start, don't you, with the stuff, with the regalia. Is that right? Well, so when you say the roots of coronation are ancient, you can trace them back through time. They're not just Victorian inventions. On what basis can you make that case? Well, so there is bling, coronation, regalia, orbs and scepters and swords and gloves and garters and all kinds of things will be coming out. And most of this stuff dates back to the time of Charles II. Yes.
苏格兰历史追溯到的这种延续性，正是为这些岛屿的历史发挥了这种作用。我的意思是，这真的太迷人了。那么，让我们首先来看看加冕典礼的一些方面，汤姆。所以你想从加冕御宝开始，对吧？好吧，当你谈到加冕典礼的根源是古老的时候，你可以随着时间的推移追溯它们。它们不仅仅是维多利亚时代的虚构发明。你凭什么能提出这样的观点？好吧，所以这里有珠宝、加冕御宝、宝球、权杖、宝剑、手套、嘉德勋章以及各种各样的东西都会亮相。而这些东西大多可以追溯到查理二世时期。是的。
So he gets crowned in 1661 after he's come back from exile. And the reason that he has to have all the crown jewels made for him is because they'd gone missing in the interregnum that separated Charles II's coronation from the execution of his father, Charles I. Because obviously, for the republic that gets established in the wake of Charles I's execution, the royal regalia are seen as possessed of a kind of malevolent power. Their potency is something to be disposed of. Not everything is destroyed. So there were three ceremonial swords that were used in the coronation of Charles I. But a lot of the regalia was much older than that, that got destroyed.
因此他在流亡归来后于 1661 年加冕。他之所以必须为自己制作所有的王冠珠宝，是因为它们在将查理二世的加冕典礼与其父亲查理一世被处决隔开的空位期（interregnum）中失踪了。因为显然，对于在查理一世被处决后建立的共和国来说，皇家御宝被视为拥有某种恶毒的力量。它们的威力是需要被清除的东西。并非所有东西都被摧毁了。所以有三把在查理一世加冕典礼上使用的礼仪剑。但许多御宝比那个还要古老，那些都被摧毁了。
And really the only medieval piece of regalia that seems to have survived is a spoon that they use for the anointing. So they kind of dip it in the holy oil that we will definitely be coming to, which is used for the anointing of the monarch. Perhaps goes back to the, I don't know, coronation of Richard I, something like that. Richard the Lionheart. It'd be great to have Richard the Lionheart's spoon, wouldn't it? Yeah, well, Archbishop of Canterbury will be using it. I mean, very exciting. Yeah.
实际上唯一幸存下来的中世纪御宝是一把用于涂油礼的勺子。所以他们会把它浸入圣油中——我们肯定会讲到圣油——圣油是用来给君王涂抹圣油的。也许可以追溯到，我不知道，理查一世的加冕典礼，诸如此类。狮心王理查。有一把狮心王理查的勺子不是很酷吗？是的，好吧，坎特伯雷大主教将使用它。我的意思是，非常令人兴奋。是的。
And so the question of where the medieval regalia came from, again, people in the Middle Ages assumed that it ultimately came from Edward the Confessor. I mean, probably didn't. Probably kind of collected over the course of the decades and the centuries. But the assumption was that it was very, very old, that it went back to the time of Edward the Confessor. And every item is kind of suffused as a result of that because it's touched by this royal saint with a, can I say, sacral meaning? You almost certainly will. Well, I have.
那么关于中世纪御宝来源的问题，同样地，中世纪的人们认为它最终来自忏悔者爱德华。我的意思是，可能并不是。它可能是随着几十年和几个世纪的推移慢慢收集起来的。但当时的假设是，它非常、非常古老，可以追溯到忏悔者爱德华的时代。因此，每一件物品都因沾染了这位皇家圣徒的气息而充满了一种——我可以说是神圣的意义吗？你几乎肯定会这么说的。我当然这么说了。
Yeah. And so Edward the Confessor is really the presiding genius of the medieval coronation, because the coronation has also always been held in Westminster Abbey, which again, Edward the Confessor built. So it was rebuilt by Henry III, but in a way that did not erase the memory of Edward the Confessor who'd originally built it. So Edward the Confessor's shrine stands at the heart of Westminster Abbey. There's this incredible pavement, Cosmati pavement, kind of very, very exquisite, distinct kind of mosaic that ultimately goes back to kind of Byzantine practice and is imbued with all kinds of geometrical and hermetic and weird significance. So that is paved both on the spot where the coronation takes place and around the tomb of the confessor. So it's kind of joining each monarch as he or she is crowned with the idea of Edward
是的。所以忏悔者爱德华确实是中世纪加冕典礼的主持精灵，因为加冕典礼也一直在威斯敏斯特教堂举行，而这也是忏悔者爱德华建造的。它后来由亨利三世重建，但重建的方式并没有抹去最初建造它的忏悔者爱德华的记忆。因此，忏悔者爱德华的神龛矗立在威斯敏斯特教堂的中心。这里有令人难以置信的地砖，科斯马蒂镶嵌地砖（Cosmati pavement），一种非常、非常精致且独特的马赛克工艺，最终可以追溯到拜拜庭（应为拜占庭）的做法，并被赋予了各种几何学、赫米斯神秘学和奇异的意义。因此，加冕典礼举行的地点以及忏悔者陵墓周围都铺设了这种地砖。这就将每一个加冕的君主与作为主持精灵的忏悔者爱德华的理念连接在了一起。因为你正站在那个地点。你正站在忏悔者爱德华所在的地点，或者你基本上是通过这些瓷砖与忏悔者爱德华相连，或者你基本上是通过这些瓷砖与忏悔者爱德华相连。本质上是的。然后是加冕椅，查理也将坐在上面，这是由爱德华一世委托制作的，但同样是以忏悔者爱德华命名的。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，顺便说一句，忏悔者爱德华是倒数第二个盎格鲁-撒克逊国王，对吧？是的。
the Confessor as the presiding genius. Because you're on that spot. You're on that spot where Edward the Confessor, or you're connected by the tiles, basically, to Edward the Confessor, or you're connected by the tiles, basically, to Edward the Confessor. Essentially, yes. And then the coronation chair, which again, Charles will sit in, commissioned by Edward I, but again, named after Edward the Confessor. So for those people who don't know, by the way, Edward the Confessor is the penultimate Anglo-Saxon king, isn't he? Yes.
他是那个建造了威斯敏斯特教堂的圣徒。根据你相信谁的说法，他要么把王国给了、要么没有把王国给哈罗德·戈德温森，然后这个王国最终被诺曼底的威廉夺走。所以这确实是与盎格鲁-撒克逊人的联系，对吧？嗯，被中世纪加冕的国王们认为这是一条纽带。所以爱德华一世是金雀花王朝人。他以忏悔者爱德华的名字命名，后者是几个世纪前的人，宣扬他的英格兰性对他来说非常重要。是这样的吗？是的。所以在爱德华的时代，英格兰君主国已经失去了在法国的土地。因此从某种意义上说，它被迫退回到
He's this saint who builds Westminster Abbey. He either gives or doesn't give, according to who you believe, his kingdom to Harold Godwinson, and then it ends up being taken by William of Normandy. So this really is a link with the Anglo-Saxons, isn't it? Well, it's believed to be a link by kings who were crowned over the course of the Middle Ages. So Edward I is Plantagenet. He's named after Edward the Confessor, who's centuries later, and it's really important to him to proclaim, I guess, his Englishness. Is that right? Yes. So by Edward's time, the English monarchy has lost its lands in France. And so in a sense, it's forced to fall back on the traditions of the
英格兰君主国的传统中。通过强调他们继承自一位圣洁前任的程度，他们在壮大自己的地位和威望。因此，在王座上——爱德华委托制作的这张木制王座上——你会看到背面画着忏悔者爱德华。这绝对是一种与此产生认同感的感觉。所以你有了御宝，你有了教堂和地点，这两者都可以追溯到忏悔者爱德华的记忆。但你也有拉丁语中所谓的 ordo（仪式程序），基本上就是礼拜仪式程序、礼仪、用于构建典礼的词汇。而这最终可以追溯到比忏悔者爱德华更早的时期。
English monarchy. And by emphasising the degree to which they stand in line from a saintly predecessor, they are bulking up their own status, their own prestige. And so on the throne, this wooden throne that Edward commissions, you get a painting of Edward the Confessor on the back. It's absolutely a kind of sense of identification with this. So you've got the regalia and you've got the abbey, the location, both of which go back to the memory of Edward the Confessor. But you also have what in Latin was called the ordo, basically the order of service, the liturgy, the words that are used to structure the ceremony. And this ultimately goes back even further in time than that of Edward the Confessor.
因此，这种仪式程序有过各种迭代，有过各种修订版本。其发展过程中的一个关键阶段是在 1377 年理查二世加冕时。也就是爱德华三世的儿子。少年国王。少年国王。所以它被称为《皇家之书》（Liber Regalis），至今仍保存在
So there've been various iterations of this kind of order of service, various recensions of it. There was a kind of key stage in its development in 1377 when Richard II is crowned. So that's the son of Edward III. Boy King. Boy King. So it's called the Liber Regalis and it's still preserved
威斯敏斯特教堂图书馆中。它一直是随后每一次加冕典礼的基础，也将成为周六举行的仪式的基础。但总会有一些曲折，
in the Library of Westminster Abbey to this day. And it's been the basis for every coronation that's followed and will be the basis for the ritual that is staged on Saturday. But there are always twists,
不是吗，汤姆？因为我们会在后面的某些剧集中深入探讨这些，特别是当英格兰被宗教争议所搅动时。人们总是在对其进行调整，使其或多或少地带有天主教或新教色彩，诸如此类。是的，就像你可能会改变奥运会项目的数量、开幕式或诸如此类的事情一样。但核心理念保持不变。没错。那么核心理念是什么呢？好吧，这是一个我们知道可以追溯到 10 世纪的仪式程序。所以这基本上比忏悔者爱德华和 1066 年的事件早了一个世纪。
aren't there, Tom? Because we'll go into those in some of the later episodes, particularly when England is sort of being roiled by religious controversy. People are always fiddling with it to make it more or less Catholic or Protestant or whatever. Yes, in much the same way that you might change, say, the number of sports at the Olympics or the opening ceremony or that kind of thing. But the core idea remains the same. Right. So what is the core idea? Well, so this is an order of service that we know goes back to the 10th century. So that is basically a century before Edward the Confessor and the events of 1066.
具体来说，它可追溯到公元 973 年，也就是一位名叫埃德加的国王加冕的时候。埃德加是阿尔弗雷德大帝的曾孙。他是英格兰第一位国王埃塞尔斯坦的侄子。他被尊称为“和平者”埃德加（Edgar the Pacificus）。这并不意味着他是个嬉皮士，恰恰相反。他极其残酷。这基本上意味着在他的统治下，英格兰保持了和平。埃德加以高度的残酷手段强加秩序。他做到了，多米尼克，你可能会说他这么做是对的。所以他弄瞎罪犯的眼睛、剥掉他们的头皮、把他们绞死。所以在 969 年——也就是他加冕前四年——肯特郡有一些匪徒
And specifically, it goes back to the year 973, which is when a king called Edgar is crowned. And Edgar is the greatson of Alfred the Great. He is the nephew of Athelstan, the first king of England. He is commemorated as Pacificus, the peaceable, the peace giver. This doesn't mean that he's a hippie, quite the opposite. He's incredibly brutal. It means basically that under his rule, England is kept at peace. And Edgar imposes order with a great degree of brutality. He does it, Dominic, and you might say that he's right to do it. So he blinds criminals, he scalps them, he hangs them. So 969, so that's four years before his coronation. There are bandits in Kent
绑架并抢劫了一些从约克南下的商人。埃德加对此的反应是蹂躏整个郡。所以他提出了一个（robust）充满活力、对待法律和秩序采取非常类似苏拉·布雷弗曼（Suela Braverman）式的强硬方法。等等。抱歉，那是在他加冕之前吗？所以他加冕前已经是国王了？是的。所以加冕典礼来得很晚。
who kidnap and rob some merchants who've come down from York. And Edgar's response to this is to ravage the entire county. So he puts it, you know, robust, very Suela Braverman approach to law and order. But hold on. Sorry, is that before he's crowned? So he's king before he's crowned? He is. And so the coronation is quite late.
是在他统治好几年之后，关于原因众说纷纭。但很明显，我认为，发生的事情是，盎格鲁-撒克逊教会历史上最伟大的教士之一——一个名叫邓斯坦、后来成为圣徒的人——代表着一种强烈的愿望。人们流传着关于他的不可思议的故事。据说他用一对火钳捉弄了魔鬼，并一把抓住魔鬼的鼻子，把他拖来拖去。所以他是教会的一位伟大亲王。我认为邓斯坦和埃德加两人合力，试图宣扬这个初生的英格兰王国、这个统一的英格兰王国。而这个王国据推测才存在了几十年。因此，被尊为英格兰第一位国王的埃塞尔斯坦，他将诺森比亚、
It's several years into his reign and dispute as to what this may be. But it's clear, I think, that what is going on is a desire on the part of probably the greatest churchman in the history of the Anglo-Saxon church, a man called Dunstan, who subsequently becomes a saint. Incredible stories are told of him. He's meant to have surprised the devil with a pair of tongs and grabbed the devil by the nose and kind of dragged him around. So he's a great prince of the church. And I think Dunstan and Edgar, between them, trying to proclaim this nascent kingdom of England, this united kingdom of England. Which has only existed for a matter of decades, presumably. So Athelstan, who is commemorated as the first king of England, he's stitched together Northumbria,
麦西亚、东盎格利亚、威塞克斯缝合成了这样一个王国，但自从埃塞尔斯坦去世后，它的一些部分又脱落了。在埃德加采取强硬的法律与秩序方法以及铸币方法下，它们又被缝合在了一起。所以正是在埃德加统治时期，国王宣布只有他才能铸造法定货币。因此有一种观点认为，他们正试图在将要成为英格兰的土地上创建一个统一国家。我认为他们有一种雄心，要上演一场能够体现这一点的加冕仪式。而埃德加对此的兴趣显然在于，他不仅将以国王的身份统治它，还将以最高统治者（imperator）、以皇帝的身份统治它。而邓斯坦的兴趣在于，他掌控了所有类型的仪式，
Mercia, East Anglia, Wessex, into this kind of kingdom that since Athelstan has died, bits of it have dropped off. They've been sewn back on together again under Edgar with his robust approach to law and order and also indeed to coinage. So it's under Edgar that the king proclaims that only he can mint legal tender. So there's this idea that they're trying to create a unitary state in what will become England. And I think there is an ambition to stage a coronation ritual that will make this manifest. And Edgar's interest in this is obviously that he will rule it as not just as a king, but as an imperator, as an emperor. And Dunstan's interest is that he seizes control of all kinds of rituals
这些仪式可能仍然带有轻微的异教色彩，并将其基督教化。啊，原来如此。所以关于它的一切都有一种象征分量。因此，加冕典礼在巴斯举行，那里至今仍散落着罗马统治的碎片和遗迹。这是一种非常明显的标志，表明你是罗马皇帝的继承人，而人们认为罗马皇帝是那些极其神秘的人物。绝对是的。所以这就是埃德加称自己为 Imperator（皇帝）的意义所在。没错。
that may still have slight pagan connotations and Christianizes them. Ah, okay. So everything about it has a kind of symbolic heft. So the coronation is staged in Bath, which is still littered with fragments and remains of Roman rule. So that's a sort of very visible sign that you are the heirs to the Roman emperors, who people think of as these tremendous mystical characters. Absolutely. And so that's the significance of Edgar calling himself Imperator, Emperor. Right.
他是在五旬节加冕的，那是圣灵降临并降临在使徒身上的日子。圣灵降临在国王身上的这种观念，是随后的几十年和几个世纪中演变而来的仪式中至关重要的一部分。而且，正如我们将看到的，这也是这个仪式史前史的一部分。因此，仪式程序似乎是由邓斯坦起草的。它基于更早的礼仪，至少可以追溯到埃塞尔斯坦时代，但也可能比那古老得多。所以这是一个学者们争论不休的问题。它以一种前所未有的加冕典礼从未有过的壮观方式呈现，以至于《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》实际上对其进行了两次描述，一次用散文，一次用诗歌。这似乎就是为什么它被记录下来的原因。
And he is crowned on Pentecost, which is the day that the Holy Spirit comes down and descends on the apostles. And this idea that the Holy Spirit descends on the king is a crucial part of the ritual as it evolves over the decades and centuries that follow. And indeed, as we'll see, is part of the prehistory of this ritual. So the order of service seems to have been drawn up by Dunstan. And it's based on an earlier liturgy going back at least to the time of Athelstan, but maybe much, much earlier than that. So it's something that scholars furiously debate. It is spectacular in a way that no previous coronation seems to have been spectacular, to the extent that the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle actually describes it twice, once in prose and once in poetry. And this seems to be why it is written
因此我们掌握的关于它的记录实际上要晚得多，但对它的记忆被保留下来，作为一件真正值得纪念的事情。很明显，除了盛典的宏大之外，还有埃德加谦逊的幽灵。记住，埃德加是一个强硬、冷酷的人。但当他走进教堂时，他摘下王冠，把它放在祭坛上，然后在祭坛前俯卧膜拜。据说邓斯坦看到这一幕时，为这种在上帝、在基督面前的卑躬屈膝的景象喜极而泣。这为埃德加宣誓的一系列三项誓言做好了铺垫，他在誓言中承诺遵守真正的和平，在所有事情上表现出公正和仁慈，
up. So the accounts we have of it are actually quite a bit later, but the memory of it is preserved as something that is really worth kind of commemorating. And it's evident that as well as the splendor of the occasion, there is also the specter of Edgar's humility. So remember, Edgar is a tough, hard man. But when he comes into the abbey, he takes off his crown, puts it on the altar, and then prostrates himself before the altar. And it's said that Dunstan at the sight of this wept with joy at the spectacle of this abasement before God, before Christ. And this serves to preface a series of three oaths that are sworn by Edgar, where he promises to observe true peace, to show justice and mercy in all things,
克制暴力。在此之前，这些都是他的臣民必须发下的誓言。但现在埃德加把自己塑造为他的人民的仆人。这再次融入了加冕仪式的主流，并将成为周六仪式的一个特点。确实如此。这是一个迷人的元素。
to refrain from violence. And previously, these were oaths that his subjects had had to swear. But now Edgar is casting himself as the servant of his people. And this again is something that passes into the kind of the mainstream of the coronation ritual and will be a feature of the ritual on Saturday. Exactly. So this is a fascinating element.
你知道，盎格鲁-撒克逊时代是一个人们极其严肃对待誓言的时代。你向你的领主发誓。你做出各种承诺。如果你阅读其中一部北欧萨加（saga）或者某种盎格鲁-撒克逊诗歌，我不知道，比如《贝奥武夫》（Beowulf）之类的，你不会发了誓然后又打破它。因此，对于埃德加在人民眼中发下这个誓言——我的意思是，他在向他的人民发誓，对吧？以及这种“人民的公仆”的理念。
You know, the Anglo-Saxon age is one in which people take oaths incredibly seriously. You swear an oath to your lord. You make all kinds of promises. If you read one of the Norse sagas or something or one of the the Anglo-Saxon poems, I don't know, Beowulf or something, you don't swear an oath and then break it. So for Edgar to swear this oath in the eyes of his people, I mean, he's swearing to his people, right? And this idea of the servant of the people.
他实际上是在向上帝发誓。他把自己作为人民的仆人许诺给上帝。他实际上是在向上帝发誓。他把自己作为人民的仆人献给上帝。所以这很新颖吗，汤姆？我的意思是，罗马皇帝不会把自己视为人民的仆人，对吧？因此，阿尔弗雷德显然有一种自我意识，认为他将为自己作为国王所做的事情在上帝面前负责。我认为基督教国王绝对有这种意识。但我认为，这其中似乎新颖的地方在于，埃德加将其作为围绕他正式即位仪式的环绕部分。我认为，这是为后代确立的加冕仪式中最具决定性的一个方面。但还有其他的。所以周六的国王
He's swearing to God, really. He's pledging himself to God as the servant of the people. He's swearing to God, really. He's pledging himself to God as the servant of his people. So is that new, Tom? I mean, a Roman emperor would not have seen himself as the servant of his people, would he? So Alfred clearly had a sense of himself as someone who would answer before God for what he did as king. I think that Christian kings absolutely did have that sense. But I think that what seems to be new about this is that Edgar is making it part of the ritual surrounding his formal enthronement. And this is, I think, the most decisive aspect of the coronation ritual that gets established for future generations. But there are others. So the king on Saturday
将由两位主教护送，即达勒姆主教和巴斯与韦尔斯主教。同样，埃德加进入巴斯修道院加冕时，也是由两位主教护送的。我们不知道他们是谁，但看起来很可能是韦尔斯主教，因为那是离巴斯最近的主教辖区。既然我们知道后来是达勒姆主教，那可能就是切斯特勒街（Chester-le-Street）的主教，圣卡斯伯特（St. Cuthbert）的遗物就在那里。所以那里可能与卡斯伯特有某种联系。还有一种观念，即坎特伯雷大主教是为国王加冕的人。所以邓斯坦显然是负责这个仪式的人。是的。多年来有一些有趣的例外。
will be escorted by two bishops, the Bishop of Durham and the Bishop of Bath and Wells. Edgar, likewise, when he comes into the Abbey of Bath to be crowned, is escorted by two bishops. We're not told who they were, but it seems likely that it would have been the Bishop of Wells, perhaps, because that's the closest bishopric to Bath. Since we know that subsequently it was the Bishop of Durham, it was probably the bishop in Chester-le-Street, which is where St. Cuthbert had his relics. So there's probably a link to Cuthbert there. And also the idea that the Archbishop of Canterbury is the man who will crown the king. So Dunstan clearly is the person who has taken charge of this ritual. Yeah. There have been a few interesting exceptions through the years.
是的，有一些例外。所以征服者威廉是由约克大主教加冕的，而亨利二世年轻的儿子——在亨利二世仍然在世时加冕的小亨利国王——也是由约克大主教加冕的。威廉和玛丽，汤姆，如果我们跳跃到前面，预料我们下一集的内容，17世纪发生了各种宗教骚乱，大主教拒绝参加加冕典礼。但大体上，由坎特伯雷大主教来执行的理念在这一点上似乎再次确立了。
Yeah, there have been a few exceptions. So William the Conqueror was crowned by the Archbishop of York, and the young son of Henry II, who was crowned while Henry II was still alive, Henry the Young King, he was crowned by the Archbishop of York as well. William and Mary, Tom, if we're jumping ahead, anticipating our next episode, there's all kinds of religious ructions going on in the 17th century, and archbishops refusing to take part in coronations. But by and large, the idea that it should be the Archbishop of Canterbury again seems to be established at this point.
同样，看看周六将要发生的事情，卡米拉将作为王后加冕，我们知道埃德加的妻子阿尔弗里特（Alfrith）与埃德加一起接受了涂油礼和加冕。这种在加冕典礼上，王后与国王一同加冕的理念。同样，这似乎也是在这个仪式中确立的。因为在此之前，有一种传统——麦西亚伟大的国王奥法（Offa）行为非常糟糕。据说她毒死了她的丈夫并逃到了大陆，拒绝了查理曼大帝，成为了一家修道院的女修道院院长。与各种人发生了丑闻。被驱逐并最终成为意大利北部帕维亚街头的乞丐。所以萨利克法典（Salic Law，原文作Salic du Tel）基本上意味着英格兰国王没有王后，但这改变了，可能是在欧洲大陆君主制的影响下。
And again, looking at what will be happening on Saturday, where Camilla will be crowned as queen, we know that Edgar's wife, Alfrith, that she is anointed and crowned alongside Edgar. And this idea that at coronations, queens as well as kings should be crowned. Again, this seems to be established at this ritual. Because prior to that, there was a kind of tradition Offa, the great king of Mercia, who'd behaved very badly. She was said to have poisoned her husband and run away to the mainland, turned down Charlemagne, become the abbess of a convent. Scandalous goings on with all kinds of people. Gets expelled and ends up a beggar on the streets of Pavia in North Italy. So the Salic du Tel, that had basically meant that English kings didn't have queens, but this gets changed, probably under the influence of continental monarchies.
所以这很耐人寻味，尽管我们已经历经数个世纪回到了 10 世纪——御宝在某种程度上可以追溯到忏悔者爱德华，威斯敏斯特教堂，以及根据你的计算方法，先后有 38、39 或 40 位英格兰和英国国王及女王在那里加冕。而仪式程序一直可以追溯到埃德加。但问题是，这个仪式的元素来自哪里？我的意思是，邓斯坦并不只是凭空捏造它们。所以它可以追溯得更远。它确实可以追溯得更远。
And so this is what's intriguing, is that even though we've gone back right the way through the centuries back to the 10th century, so the regalia, going back to Edward the Confessor in a kind of way, Westminster Abbey, and depending on how you count them, there have been either 38, 39 or 40 English kings and queens, British kings and queens who've been crowned there. And the order of service going all the way back to Edgar. But then the question is, where are the elements of this ritual coming from? I mean, Dunstan isn't just making them up. So it goes back even further. It does go back even further.
太棒了。以各种奇怪和意想不到的方式。我们是不是应该在这里休息一下？我们应该休息一下，休息过后，汤姆将深入探讨加冕典礼的神秘之处。请不要离开。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
Excellent. In all kinds of strange and unexpected ways. So should we take a break here? We should take a break and Tom will be delving deeper into the mysteries of coronations after the break. Please don't go away. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加赠剧集以及现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们向你承诺过加冕典礼的神秘之处，而汤姆·霍兰德，兑现这个承诺就是你的任务。好的。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We promised you the mysteries of coronations, and that, Tom Holland, is your task to deliver on that promise. Okay.
所以我们谈到了埃德加，无论那是哪一年，是 973 年还是别的什么？是的。是的，那是 973 年在巴斯。邓斯坦，坎特伯雷大主教，这对他是确立自己首要地位的一个绝佳机会，我猜。是的。但你在前半部分结束时说过，邓斯坦并没有凭空捏造加冕仪式和加冕典礼。
So we talked about Edgar whenever it was, 973 was it or something like that? Yeah. Yeah, it was 973 in Bath. Dunstan, the Archbishop of Canterbury, it's a great opportunity for him to sort of assert his primacy, I suppose. Yeah. But you were saying at the end of the first half, Dunstan doesn't make up the coronation service and the coronation rituals.
他是从某个地方得到的。是的。我的理解是否正确，他不仅从某种基督教传统中获取这些？他还从异教传统中获取？这其中似乎隐含着异教实践的隐秘线索。因此，在盎格鲁-撒克逊世界的基督教时期之前，国王加冕的方式之一——实际上横跨了罗马帝国之后的那些蛮族王国——是他们的国王身份的确立不是用王冠标志，而是用头盔标志。因此，埃塞尔斯坦似乎是第一位用王冠而不是头盔加冕的国王。还有，国王应该由主教护送，而不是由他的随从武士（thanes）护送的理念。
He's getting it from somewhere. Yeah. Am I right in thinking that he's not just getting it from kind of Christian traditions? He's getting it from pagan ones as well. There seem to be kind of shadowy hints of pagan practice beneath it. So one of the ways in which kings in the pre-Christian period in the Anglo-Saxon world seem to have been crowned and actually across the barbarian kingdoms that follow the Roman Empire is that their initiation as a king is marked not with a crown, but with a helmet. So Athelstan seems to have been the first king to have been crowned with a crown rather than with a helmet. Also, the idea that a king should be escorted by bishops rather than by his thanes.
所以我认为这是为了消除异教国王被他的军阀们像《阿斯特里克斯》（Asterix）里通过生命体征那样高高举在盾牌上的民间记忆。所以我认为这就是正在发生的事情。这其中也有对英国本身就非常古老的基督教传统的刻意呼应。因此，邓斯坦作为埃德加的梅林（Merlin）就如同亚瑟王的梅林，这在英国也是一种流传非常久远的现象。事实上，我的意思是，这是一种奇妙的讽刺，也许我们的爱尔兰听众会喜欢，即在英国第一个为国王举行即位典礼的人实际上是一个爱尔兰人。那就是圣科伦巴（St. Columba），尼斯湖水怪的宿敌，我们在多个场合谈论过他。所以他离开爱尔兰并
So I think it's an attempt to get rid of the folk memory of a pagan king being lifted by vital statistics in Asterix up on a shield by his warlords. So I think that's what's going on. There's also a deliberate echoing of Christian traditions in Britain that are themselves very ancient. So the idea of Dunstan as Merlin to Edgar's Arthur, this again is something that goes back a very long way in Britain. And actually, I mean, it's kind of wonderful irony that perhaps our Irish listeners will enjoy that the first man to inaugurate a king in Britain is actually an Irishman. And that's St. Columba, the enemy of the Loch Ness Monster, who we've talked about on several occasions. So he's left Ireland and he's
来到了达尔里阿达王国（kingdom of Dalriada），该王国横跨爱尔兰和苏格兰西海岸之间的海域。那是公元6世纪晚期吗？是的。因此他闻名遐迩地在爱奥那岛（Iona）建立了一座修道院。一位天使向他显现，命令他去为一个名叫埃丹（Aedan）的国王加冕。而科伦巴不想这么做，因为他更喜欢埃丹的兄弟。但天使掏出一根鞭子抽打了他。据说那鞭痕留在了科伦巴的身上，伴随了他余生。天使说：“如果你不去，我会再给你一顿鞭笞。”于是科伦巴照着被告知的做了。现在，关于这件事的记载
come to the kingdom of Dalriada, which kind of spans the seas between Ireland and the west coast of Scotland. And that was what, late 6th century? Yeah. And so he famously establishes a monastery on Iona, the island of Iona. And an angel appears to him and orders him to go and crown a king called Aedan. And Columbus doesn't want to do this because he's keener on Aden's brother. But the angel draws out a whip and lashes him. And the mark of that lash, it is said, stayed on Columbus' body for the rest of his life. And the angel says, if you don't go and do it, I'll give you another lashing. And so Columbus goes and does what he's told. Now, the account
不出所料并非同时代的。所以它晚了一个世纪，但似乎相当真实。如果它是真的，那么这就是英国任何地方、甚至可以说是欧洲任何地方关于基督教即位仪式的最早的清晰记载。不仅如此，在整个欧洲也是如此。是这样的吗？是的，差不多。不管它是否真实，到了 7 世纪末，爱奥那岛的修道院院长们确实在以与坎特伯雷大主教后来为英格兰国王加冕完全相同的方式，为主持达尔里阿达国王的祝圣仪式。一个非常简单的问题。这发生在苏格兰，汤姆。
of this predictably isn't contemporaneous. So it's a century later, it seems to be pretty authentic. And if it is authentic, then it's the first clear account of a Christian inauguration ritual anywhere in Britain. And more than that, anywhere in Europe. Is that right? Yeah, pretty much. And whether it's authentic or not, it's definitely the case by the late 7th century, abbots of Iona are consecrating kings of Dalriada in exactly the same way that Archbishop of Canterbury will go on to consecrate kings of England. Very quick question. This is taking place in Scotland, Tom.
我对苏格兰加冕仪式的了解可能没有那么深入和亲密。但我假设它们涉及巨大的石头。这是正确的吗？好吧。所以石头是另一个事物，是英国本土传统的一个特征。因此，埃塞尔斯坦是在泰晤士河畔金斯顿的一块石头上加冕的。另外七位
And my understanding of Scottish coronation rituals is perhaps not as close and intimate as it could be. But my assumption is they involve enormous stones. Is that correct? Right. Okay. So stones is another thing, another feature of, seems to be kind of insular traditions in Britain. So Athelstan is crowned on a stone at Kingston on Thames. Seven other
国王也在金斯顿的这块石头上加冕，这块石头据称至今仍在。那可能确实是一种维多利亚时代发明的传统。这块石头是否真实，我们不得而知。但如果你在金斯顿，你可以去看看。不过，国王们加冕的那块著名的石头，当然是斯康石（Stone of Scone）。在早期中世纪苏格兰历史的进程中，国王加冕的地点呈现出一种向东迁移的趋势。它从爱奥那岛迁移到中阿盖尔郡（mid-Argyle）一个叫邓纳德（Dunad）的地方。那里有一块岩石，上面有一个类似于脚印的凹痕，国王会把脚放进这个凹痕里，这象征着他与他即将统治的土地的
kings as well are crowned on the stone in Kingston and Thames, which is still there, supposedly. That really might be a kind of invented Victorian tradition. Whether the stone is authentic or not, we don't know. But if you're in Kingston, you can go and see that. But the famous stone on which kings are crowned is, of course, the Stone of Scone. There's a sense in which over the course of early medieval Scottish history, the place where kings are being crowned migrates eastwards. It goes from Iona to a place called Dunad in mid-Argyle. This is where there's a rock with an indentation that resembles a foot, and the king will put his foot into this indentation, and it kind of symbolizes his marriage to the living rock
活生生的岩石的联姻。但当苏格兰西部的达尔里阿达和东部的皮克兰（Pickland）融合成苏格兰人的土地、即后来的苏格兰王国时。加冕典礼的中心已经迁移到了位于珀斯郡（Perthshire）的斯康（Scone）。众所周知，那里的国王都是在斯康石上加冕的。人们称之为命运之石。命运之石。那么，命运之石到底是什么？现在流传着关于这块石头的各种故事。因此，有一个传统说它是雅各布的石头，雅各布是亚伯拉罕的孙子，从长远来看他是以色列十二支派的父亲。他躺下睡觉，把一块石头当枕头休息，他看到了伟大的
of the lands that he's coming to rule. But by the time that Dalriada in the west of Scotland and Pickland in the east has kind of been fused into the land of the Scots, what will become the Kingdom of Scotland. The centre of coronations has migrated to Scone, which is in Perthshire. And famously, kings there are crowned on the Stone of Scone. Stone of Destiny, people call it. Stone of Destiny. Now, what is the Stone of Destiny? Now, there are various stories that are told about this. So one tradition says that it is the stone that Jacob, who is the grandson of Abraham, the father of the 12 tribes of Israel in the long run. He lies down to sleep and he rests his head on a stone for a pillow and he sees a great
天使异象。而这块石头正是作为雅各布枕头的石头。它后来被先知耶利米和巴比伦人洗劫前犹大最后一任国王的女儿（一个名叫蒂亚（Teah）的女子）带走了。他们去了埃及。她后来改名为斯科塔（Scota），然后把这块石头带到了爱尔兰。正是在爱尔兰，它获得了“命运之石”的名字。据说它曾位于塔拉（Tara）遗址，那是爱尔兰至高王加冕的圣山。然后它被科伦巴带到爱奥那岛，再到邓纳德，最后到斯康。这些就是传说。其中的复杂之处在于，这些传说其实相当晚近。它们紧随其后的是
vision of angels. And this stone is that very stone that was Jacob's pillow. It had then been taken by the prophet Jeremiah and the daughter of the last king of Judah before it's sacked by the Babylonians, a woman called Teah. They go to Egypt. She then takes on the name Scotta and she then takes the stone of to Ireland. And it's in Ireland that it gets the name, the stone of destiny. It's said to have been on the site of Tara, the holy hill on which the High Kings of Ireland were crowned. And then it's brought by Clumber to Iona, then to Dunad, and then to Schoon. So those are the stories. Complication with that is that these stories actually are quite late. They follow what is
这块石头历史上最臭名昭著的一段插曲，那就是被“苏格兰之锤”爱德华一世劫掠。爱德华一世企图征服苏格兰，他认为通过将命运之石移到威斯敏斯特教堂——他在那里建造了加冕宝座、即忏悔者爱德华的宝座，使其能够容纳斯康石——通过这样做，他将剥夺任何潜在苏格兰国王的合法性。正是英格兰人讲述了这块石头实际上是雅各布用作枕头的石头的故事。而苏格兰人则讲述了它是如何来自爱尔兰塔拉的故事。关于这块石头，令人沮丧的真相是，地质学家检查了这块石头，它似乎既不是来自
probably the most notorious episode in the history of this stone, which is its abduction by Edward I, the Hammer of the Scots, who is trying to conquer Scotland and thinks that by removing the Stone of Destiny to Westminster Abbey, where he has the coronation throne, the throne of Edward the Confessor, built so that it can contain the Stone of Scone, that by doing that, he will be delegitimising any would-be kings of Scotland. And it's the English who tell the story about how this is actually the stone used by Jacob as a pillow. And it's the Scots who say how it came from Tara and Ireland. The depressing truth about this is that geologists have looked at the stone and it seems to have come neither from
这块石头历史上最臭名昭著的事件，莫过于被“苏格兰人的锤子”英格兰国王爱德华一世劫走。他试图征服苏格兰，认为只要把命运之石带到威斯敏斯特教堂——他在那里建造了加冕宝座即忏悔者爱德华的宝座，好让它容纳斯康石——通过这样做，他就能使任何未来的苏格兰国王失去合法性。正是英格兰人讲述了这块石头实际上是雅各用作枕头的故事。而苏格兰人则讲述了它如何来自爱尔兰的塔拉。关于这件事令人沮丧的真相是，地质学家研究了这块石头，发现它似乎既不来自……
the Holy Land nor from Ireland. It seems to have come from Perthshire. So very sad. But that remains a living link with those fabulously ancient traditions, because the Stone of Scone will be brought back from Scotland where it got sent by John Major in, I think, 1996. Yes. And it will be brought back. I think it's already been brought back. And Charles will be enthroned sitting on top of it.
既不是圣地，也不是爱尔兰。它似乎来自珀斯郡。真是令人难过。但这仍然与那些极其古老的传统保持着活生生的联系，因为斯康石将被从苏格兰带回，它是在1996年左右被约翰·梅杰送到那里的，我想是的。是的。它将被带回来。我想它已经带回来了。查尔斯将坐在它的上面登基。
There's a very famous story about it, isn't there? Was it in 1950 or so? Yeah, 1950. Yeah. Yeah. Some students, some nationalist students, students they stole it didn't they they stole it um and tried to smuggle it back to scotland they did because there were roadblocks everywhere but they managed to get it and as they took it over they um kind of baptized it with whiskey right to celebrate the fact that it was
关于它有一个非常著名的故事，对吧？是在1950年左右吗？对，1950年。是的。是的。有些学生，一些民族主义学生，学生们把它偷走了，对吧，他们把它偷走了，呃，并试图把它走私回苏格兰，他们确实这么做了，因为到处都是路障，但他们设法拿到了它，当他们把它运过去的时候，他们呃用威士忌给它“洗礼”了，对吧，为了庆祝它
back where it should be and then they hid it in the ruins of arbroath abbey and it got found and sent back to westminster abbey in 1952 It's a good place to hide a big stone. Yeah. And the weird thing is, even Cromwell seems to have taken it quite seriously. So when he was installed as Lord Protector, he was installed sitting on the throne that had the stone underneath it. And the irony is that Charles II, long before he was crowned in Westminster Abbey in 1661, he'd been crowned a decade earlier in Scone, where of course, the Stone of Destiny had long gone. Cromwell had it. So again, one of the wonderful ironies that seems to shadow this whole story. So that's the backdrop of weirdness that I think is feeding into the coronation rituals that come
回到了它应该在的地方，然后把它藏在阿布罗斯修道院的废墟里，它被找到了，并在1952年被送回了威斯敏斯特修道院。这是藏一块大石头的好地方。是的。奇怪的是，连克伦威尔似乎也很严肃地对待它。所以当他被立为护国公时，他是坐在下方有这块石头的宝座上就职的。具有讽刺意味的是，查理二世早在1661年在威斯敏斯特修道院加冕之前十几年，就已经在斯康加冕了，当然，命运之石当时已经不在那里了。克伦威尔把它拿走了。所以这又是贯穿这个整个故事的奇妙讽刺之一。这就是我认为融入了英国加冕典礼的那些诡异背景。
from Britain. But the truth is that there are other elements of the ritual that look to the continent. So some of these rituals are clearly Roman. So I really wanted to ask about this. Roman emperors weren't crowned in any meaningful way, were they? They come to be crowned in the third century. So when the empire is kind of collapsing. They had a coronation every three days in that case. Right. Well, they may not have had coronations,
但事实是，仪式中还有其他元素是看向欧洲大陆的。因此，其中一些仪式显然是罗马式的。所以我真的很想问这个问题。罗马皇帝并没有以任何有意义的方式加冕，对吧？他们在公元三世纪开始加冕。所以当帝国正在崩溃的时候。如果是那样的话，他们每三天就会举行一次加冕典礼。对。好吧，他们可能没有举行加冕典礼，
but they come to be portrayed with the crowns that kind of show the rays of the sun, kind of radiant crowns. And with Constantine and then his heirs, the wearing of a diadem comes to be part of the kind of the ritual display. And certainly by the end of the fifth century, you were having formal coronations
但他们开始被描绘成戴着某种显示太阳光芒的皇冠，也就是放射状的皇冠。随着君士坦丁以及后来的继承人，佩戴皇带（diadem）成为仪式展示的一部分。当然，到了公元五世纪末，你就会看到罗马皇帝在君士坦丁堡的大圣索菲亚大教堂举行正式的加冕典礼。
of Roman emperors in the great cathedral of Hagia Sophia in Constantinople. And over the centuries that follow, these coronation rituals in Hagia Sophia become kind of more and more sacral, can I say? More and more ritualized. And that Cosmati pavement in Westminster Abbey that we talked about in the first half is modeled ultimately on the marble pavement in Hagia Sophia that under Roman presumptions marked the center of the world on which the Roman emperors are crowned. So this desire to emulate Roman models, it's there in the reign of Henry III, but it's also much earlier because say Athelstan, when he's having himself crowned as king with a crown rather than with a helmet, he can look at examples from Roman coins. Of people with crowns, and they're wearing crowns because of the sun.
在随后的几个世纪里，圣索菲亚大教堂的这些加冕仪式变得越来越神圣，我可以这么说吗？越来越仪式化。我们在前半部分讨论过的威斯敏斯特修道院里的科斯马蒂（Cosmati）地铺，最终模仿的就是圣索菲亚大教堂的大理石地铺，在罗马人的设想中，它标志着世界的中心，罗马皇帝正是在这里加冕的。因此，这种效仿罗马模特的愿望，在亨利三世统治时期就存在了，但它也更早，因为比如埃塞尔斯坦，当他用王冠而不是头盔把自己加冕为国王时，他可以参考罗马硬币上的例子。那些戴着皇冠的人，他们戴着皇冠是因为太阳。
That had never occurred to me before. That's really interesting. Yeah. For Athelstan, as with Edgar, Athelstan is describing himself as an imperator, which is the Latin name for emperor. The fact that he is laying claim to the rule of Britain, he's consciously aiming at an imperial dignity. And so that idea that they are drawing on the legacy of Roman imperial rank and status, I think again, is another element of what is feeding into this ritual. But to go back to that idea of wearing something special on your head, Alexander the Great, when he went to Persia and he conquered the Persian Empire, he shocked his generals, his pals, by wearing a diadem,
我以前从来没想过这一点。这真的很有趣。是的。对于埃塞尔斯坦来说，正如埃德加一样，埃塞尔斯坦称自己为imperator，这是皇帝的拉丁语名称。他宣称自己对英国拥有统治权，他是有意识地在追求一种帝王的尊严。因此，我认为他们汲取罗马帝国等级和地位遗产的这一理念，又是融入这一仪式的另一个要素。但回到头上戴着特殊东西的想法，亚历山大大帝当他去到波斯并征服了波斯帝国时，他戴着皇带，震惊了他的将军们，他的伙伴们，
by wearing a kind of ribbon around his head to circle it. I mean, the idea of something encircling your head that is immediately identifiable and only you can wear. So he gets that from the Persians. Could you argue that when King Charles has been crowned on Saturday and his head is being encircled with gold, that that is ultimately a Persian inheritance, Tom? I suppose if you were Ali Ansari, you could potentially argue that. Professor of history at St. Andrews is very keen on the Persians.
在他的头上缠绕着某种丝带。我的意思是，缠绕在你头上、能够立即被识别且只有你能佩戴的东西的这个概念。所以他是从波斯人那里学来的。汤姆，你能不能说，当查尔斯国王在周六加冕、他的头部被黄金环绕时，这最终是波斯人的遗产？我想如果你是阿里·安萨里，你可能会这样认为。圣安德鲁斯大学的历史学教授非常热衷于波斯人。
I think that the reason that crowns come in is because of the Roman echoes. I mean, that's what the interest is for the Anglo-Saxon kings. When we talk about Roman emperors, of course, they're not just in Constantinople. They are also from 800 AD onwards on the continent, because in 800 AD, tellingly on Christmas Day, so a kind of great sacred day, Charlemagne had been crowned by the Pope in Rome. That provides the other great model. And there's a sense in which the coronation rituals that are being practiced in England, although they are drawing on insular traditions, ultimately they are deriving from the Carolingians.
我认为引入王冠的原因是因为罗马的呼应。我的意思是，这就是盎格鲁-撒ク逊国王感兴趣的地方。当我们谈论罗马皇帝时，当然，他们不仅在君士坦丁堡。从公元800年开始，他们也出现在欧洲大陆，因为在公元800年，颇具说明意义的是在圣诞节那天——一个伟大的神圣日子——查理曼大帝在罗马被教皇加冕。这就提供了另一个伟大的典范。在某种程度上，英格兰正在实行的加冕仪式，尽管它们借鉴了本土传统，但最终它们源自加洛林王朝。
So the Carolingians are the dynasty of which Charlemagne is the greatest figure. And crownings are one manifestation of this, but there is another that is even more telling and even more significant, I think. And that is the ritual of anointing. This is what you've been building up to, isn't it? Because you love all this stuff. Sacral oils. Sacral oils.
所以加洛林王朝是以查理曼大帝为最伟大人物的王朝。加冕是其中的一种表现形式，但还有另一种表现形式，我认为它甚至更能说明问题，也更重要。那就是涂油礼。这就是你一直在铺垫的，对吧？因为你喜欢所有这些东西。神圣的油。神圣的油。
And so this is seen, I mean, it was seen by Elizabeth II when she was crowned as being the holiest moment of the ritual. Ditto for Charles III on Saturday. It's not to be filmed. It's seen as being too holy. And so the tradition is that a canopy made of silk or cloth of gold is held over the monarch, traditionally held by four knights of the garter, which is very exciting for fans of Edward III. Yeah. So that could be John Major. I can't remember who the others are. Yeah. It's quite disappointing. Yeah.
所以这被视为——伊丽莎白二世加冕时被视为仪式中最神圣的时刻。查理三世周六也是如此。它不能被拍摄。这被认为是太神圣了。因此，传统的做法是，在君王头上方撑起一个由丝绸或金布制成的华盖，传统上由嘉德骑士团的四位骑士撑着，这对于爱德华三世的粉丝来说非常激动人心。是的。所以那可能是约翰·梅杰。我不记得其他人是谁了。是的。这挺让人失望的。是的。
So not the Black Prince or anyone like that. And they are anointed with holy oil. And at the time when anointings are starting to be used in early medieval Europe. So actually the earliest reference we have to this isn't from the Carolingians. It's not in Francia. It's a Visigothic king in Spain with the brilliant name of Wamba, who's anointed in 672. But the key anointing takes place in 751 when Pippin, it's a very Tolkien-esque name, who is the first Carolingian king, is anointed at a place called Soissons. And the dynasty that he is overthrown are the Merovingians, who we talked about in the Holy Blood and Holy Grail episodes.
所以不是黑太子或类似的人。他们被圣油涂抹。而在加洛林王朝初期的欧洲，开始使用涂油礼的时候。实际上，我们掌握的关于这一做法最早的记录并非来自加洛林王朝。它不在法兰克尼亚。而是在西班牙的一个西哥特国王，他有一个非常棒的名字叫万巴（Wamba），于672年被涂油。但关键的涂油发生在751年，当时平品（Pippin）——这是一个非常有托尔金风格的名字，他是第一位加洛林王朝的国王——在一个叫苏瓦松（Soissons）的地方被涂油。他推翻的王朝是墨洛温王朝，我们在《圣血与圣杯》的单集里讨论过他们。
So they likewise claim a kind of sacral authority by virtue of descent from a sea monster. Obviously, the Carolingians can't claim that, and they're anxious about being cast as usurpers. And so they need the kind of dignity, the kind of authority, the kind of legitimacy that an anointing can provide them with. And the reason that an anointing can provide them with legitimacy is because this is a tradition that harks back to Old Testament kings. Ah, so they are anointed. Yeah, right. Well, it's confusing. So actually, the first Carolingian king to be both crowned and anointed is actually the
因此，他们同样宣称自己拥有一种神圣的权威，因为他们是海怪的后代。显然，加洛林王朝无法宣称这一点，他们很担心自己被当成篡位者。因此，他们需要涂油礼能够赋予他们的那种尊严、那种权威、那种合法性。而涂油礼能赋予他们合法性的原因，是因为这是一个可以追溯到旧约国王的传统。啊，所以他们被涂了油。对，没错。嗯，这很让人糊涂。事实上，第一位既被加冕又被涂油的加洛林王朝国王其实是
son of Charlemagne, Louis the Pious. So the Pope crosses the Alps in 816 after the death of Charlemagne and both crowns and anoints Louis the Pious. The crowning, of course, marks him out as a Roman emperor, but it also marks him out as a king in the line of descent from the ancient kings of Israel because David is crowned. But the key ritual in the Old Testament that marks out all the kings of Israel is the fact that they are anointed. Pippin and Louis the Pious and in due course, so the first reference we have to an anointing in England is the son of Offa, the King of Mercia, and then Edgar and into the Middle Ages. They can feel that they are joined by a living tradition to the Old Testament kings because actually people in the church have been anointing priests and anointing holy implements since the very beginnings of Christianity.
查理曼的儿子虔诚者路易。因此，教皇在816年查理曼死后穿过阿尔卑斯山，为虔诚者路易加冕并涂油。加冕礼当然标志着他是一位罗马皇帝，但也标志着他是传承自古代以色列诸王血统的国王，因为大卫王就是加冕的。但《旧约》中标志着所有以色列诸王的关键仪式，是他们都接受了涂油。丕平、虔诚者路易，以及后来的英格兰（我们掌握的关于英格兰涂油的最早记录是麦西亚国王奥法的儿子，然后是埃德加，一直到中世纪）。他们能感觉到，通过活生生的传统，他们与《旧约》的国王们连结在了一起，因为实际上自基督教诞生之初，教会里的人就一直在为牧师涂油，为神圣的器具涂油。
And they're doing that because in the Old Testament, they read about how priests and the holy gear that you use for rituals in the Old Testament. The holy gear. The holy gear, the holy appurtenances, whatever, regalia. But these are being anointed. And so the practice of anointing is seen by Christians as a living tradition that they've inherited from the Israelite past. And for bishops in particular, they get anointed by a particularly potent holy oil called chrism,
他们这样做是因为在《旧约》中，他们读到关于祭司以及《旧约》中仪式所使用的神圣装备。神圣的装备。神圣的装备，神圣的附属物，无论什么，王权象征。但这些都被涂上了油。因此，涂油的做法被基督徒视为他们从以色列过去继承下来的活生生的传统。特别是对于主教们，他们会被一种被称为圣油（chrism）的特别强效的神圣油膏抹，
which is believed to have incredible supernatural power. It's believed that if you're sailing at sea and there's a storm, you just scatter the chrism over the waves and the demons will fade away and the sea will be calmed. You scatter it on a field, the fields will be blessed. And if you anoint a living body with chrism, its sacral power will pass through the pores, penetrate the body, seep deep into the soul. And that this is what elevates bishops above other priests and particularly above the laity. And to start touching kings with chrism, which is something that starts to happen in this period, is touching them with an element of the sacred as well. It's turning them into
人们认为这种油具有不可思议的超自然力量。人们认为，如果你在海上航行遇到风暴，你只需要把圣油撒在海浪上，恶魔就会退去，大海就会平静。你把它撒在田野里，田野就会受到祝福。如果你用圣油涂抹活人的身体，它的神圣力量就会穿透毛孔，渗入身体，深入灵魂。正是这一点将主教们提升于其他牧师之上，尤其是凌驾于俗人之上。开始用圣油触摸国王，这是在这个时期开始发生的事情，也是在触摸他们神圣的一部分。这把他们变成了
kind of priests, kingly priests. So when you're talking about, you say, anointing them in this period, you're talking about the Carolingians rather, Pippin and Co. Yeah. And so you remember that I said about how there's this idea that the Holy Spirit descends on kings. Yeah. That's what the anointing is all about. Right. So basically, right the way from the 9th century, the anointing of a king has been marked by
某种祭司，具有国王身份的祭司。所以当你谈到你所说的这一时期的涂油时，你其实是指加洛林王朝，丕平等人。是的。所以你还记得我说过关于圣灵降临在国王身上的这种观点吗？是的。这就是涂油的全部意义所在。没错。基本上，从9世纪开始，国王的涂油仪式就一直伴随着
a particular anthem, a Latin hymn. So, Veni, Creator, Spiritus, come Holy Ghost, come Holy Spirit, and kind of fill us with inspiration is basically the idea. And there's this idea then that by anointing a king or a queen, they are literally being touched by the Holy Spirit. So, deep magic, Dominic. Very deep magic. But if this is part of the kind of the living Christian tradition that goes back to the beginnings of the church, of the living Christian tradition that goes back to the beginnings of the church, of course, it is also going back to what Christians can read in the pages of the Old Testament about the kings of the Israelites.
一个特定的赞美诗，一首拉丁圣歌。所以，Veni, Creator, Spiritus（来吧，造物主的圣灵），来吧圣灵，来吧圣灵，用灵感充满我们，基本上就是这个意思。因此这就产生了一种观念：通过给国王或女王涂油，他们字面意义上被圣灵触摸了。所以，这是深奥的魔法，多米尼克。非常深奥的魔法。但如果这是可以追溯到教会之初的活生生的基督教传统的一部分，当然，它也是可以追溯到基督徒在《旧约》书页中读到的关于以色列诸王的故事的。
So originally, the Israelites did not have kings. They had judges. But they then asked God for a king. And the prophet Samuel, who is the kind of the big cheese among the Israelites at this point, he's the Columba, he's the Dunstan, he's the prototype for the holy man who inaugurates a king. Gandalf, Merlin. Gandalf, Merlin, all that. Yes. He anoints and crowns a man called Saul, who turns out not to be a great king. He's a rotter, isn't he, Saul?
所以最初，以色列人没有国王。他们有士师。但他们随后向上帝求一个国王。先知撒母耳，他是此时以色列人中的大人物，他是科伦巴（Columba），他是邓斯坦（Dunstan），他是开创国王先河的神圣之人的原型。甘道夫，梅林。甘道夫，梅林，诸如此类。是的。他给一个叫扫罗的人涂油并加冕，结果证明扫罗不是一个伟大的国王。扫罗是个混蛋，对吧？
He turns out to be a rotter, yes. And is succeeded by David, who is the shepherd boy who kills Goliath, but then goes on to become... He's a great fellow unless you're Bathsheba's husband. Right. So, yes. So there's definitely the sense that David ends up being crowned and anointed. Yeah. And a lot of the Psalms, many of which are attributed to David,
结果证明他是个混蛋，是的。继位的是大卫，他是一个杀死歌利亚的牧羊男孩，但后来成为……他是个了不起的家伙，除非你是拔示巴的丈夫。没错。所以，是的。因此，绝对有一种感觉，大卫最终被加冕并涂油。是的。许多诗篇，其中许多归功于大卫，
there are descriptions of him being crowned and anointed. So it's kind of famous lines from one of the Psalms, many of which are attributed to David, there are descriptions of him being crowned and anointed. So it's kind of famous lines from one of the Psalms. I have found David my servant, with my holy oil have I anointed him, with whom my hand shall be established, mine arm also shall strengthen him. The enemy shall not exact upon him, nor the son of wickedness afflict him. And I will beat down his foes before his face and plague them that hate him. So this is the kind of stuff that kings in the early Middle Ages are buying into. That if they can get this anointing, then they're
都有对他被加冕和涂油的描述。所以这有点像是其中一首诗篇中的著名诗句，其中许多被归功于大卫，有对他被加冕和涂油的描述。所以它有点像其中一首诗篇的著名诗句。我寻得我的仆人大卫，用我的圣油膏了他。我的手必按手在他身上，我的膀臂也必坚固他。仇敌必不勒索他，凶恶之子必不苦害他。我要在他面前打碎他的敌人，用灾殃击打恨他的人。所以这就是中世纪早期国王们所信仰的东西。如果他们能得到这种涂油，那么他们就
kind of getting a superpower. And also, of course, because there's a certain degree of relevance for Charles III as well. David is, as you said, he's a notorious adulterer. So he lusts after Bathsheba, the wife of Uriah, who is a great captain in the Israelite army. In fact, has him killed. But this doesn't invalidate David's anointing. So that again is kind of good news for badly behaved medieval kings. Well, for like George IV or somebody. Yes. But the ultimate king and the king whose model really lies behind all the rituals of the medieval kingship going into the present day is Solomon, who is the archetype of wisdom. And so we opened with Zadok the priest, this great
有点像是获得了超能力。当然，这也因为对查理三世也有一定程度的现实意义。如你所说，大卫是一个臭名昭著的通奸犯。因此他贪恋乌利亚的妻子拔示巴，乌利亚是以色列军队中的一位伟大将领。事实上，大卫还让人杀了他。但这并没有使大卫的涂油失效。所以这对于行为不端的中世纪国王来说又是一个好消息。嗯，比如乔治四世或什么人。是的。但终极的国王，其模范真正构成了从古至今中世纪君主制所有仪式基础的国王，是所罗门，他是智慧的原型。因此我们以《祭司萨多克》开篇，这首伟大的
anthem that has been sung in coronations right the way back to the time of Edgar, but of course, is best known in the version composed by Handel. And these are drawn from verses in the Old Testament. Handel's anthem, it reads, Zadok the priest and Nathan the prophet anointed Solomon king. And all the people rejoiced and said, God save the king, long live the king, God save the king, may the king live forever. Amen. Alleluia. And this is exactly replicating the order of service that you get that is narrated for Solomon's crowning and anointing. What you get in the Old Testament version of Solomon's crowning is you get anointing of oil by a priest, then you get the people acclaim him, and then you get the king sitting on a throne. This is basically the pattern that the Christian rituals of coronation and anointing inherit and which we will be seeing on Saturday. And so, that's kind of an amazing thing. And what makes it all the more amazing,
赞美诗从埃德加时代一直到加冕典礼都在被传唱，但当然，它以亨德尔谱曲的版本最为知名。这些都取材于《旧约》中的经文。亨德尔的赞美诗写道：“祭司萨多克和先知拿单膏立所罗门为王。众民欢乐，并说：‘愿国王万岁，愿国王长寿，愿国王万岁，愿国王永远活着。阿门。哈利路亚。’”这完全复制了为所罗门加冕和涂油所描述的服事次序。你在《旧约》版本的所罗门加冕礼中看到的是，首先由祭司用油涂抹，然后民众欢呼，接着国王坐在宝座上。这基本上就是基督教加冕和涂油仪式继承的模式，也是我们在周六将要看到的模式。所以，这真是一件神奇的事情。而让这一切更加神奇的是，
I think, is that the only evidence we have for the anointing of Israelite kings is the Old Testament. And so, how reliable are these accounts? People have been very sceptical about them. But I think that they probably do preserve authentic traditions. And the reason for that is that it seems that the Israelite traditions are influenced by the kings of their neighbouring great powers, so Syria and Egypt, where there is evidence for anointing rituals happening right the way back into the Bronze Age. And I think the surest evidence for this is the fact that in the Old Testament, so the narrative back into the Bronze Age. And I think the surest evidence for this is the fact that in the Old Testament, so the narrative accounts of the lives of Saul and David and
我认为，我们掌握的关于以色列诸王涂油的唯一证据就是《旧约》。因此，这些记载有多可靠？人们对此一直非常怀疑。但我认为它们可能确实保留了真实的传统。原因在于，以色列人的传统似乎受到了他们邻近强大势力（如叙利亚和埃及）国王的影响，那里有证据表明，涂油仪式一直可以追溯到青铜时代。我认为最确凿的证据是，在《旧约》中，也就是对扫罗和大卫以及
Solomon, but also in the Psalms, there's a certain anxiety about what exactly this ritual of anointing means. Because the translation of anointed, the kind of anglicised form of Hebrew is Messiah, and the anglicised Greek form of it is Christ. So Christ is an anointed, kind of anglicized form of Hebrew is Messiah. Oh. And the anglicized Greek form of it is Christ. Right. So Christ is an anointed one. Yeah. And it seems that certainly the Syrian kings, when they were anointed, that they became in a way the son of a God, or they became divinized,
所罗门的生平的叙事记载中，在《诗篇》中也是如此，对于涂油这一仪式的确切含义存在着某种焦虑。因为“受膏者”的翻译，即希伯来语的英语化形式是“弥赛亚”（Messiah），而它的英语化希腊语形式是“基督”（Christ）。所以基督是一个受膏者，即希伯来语的英语化形式是“弥赛亚”。哦。而它的英语化希腊语形式是“基督”。没错。所以基督是一位受膏者。是的。而且看起来，当叙利亚国王被涂油时，他们似乎在某种程度上成了神的儿子，或者他们被神圣化了，
they became divine. And obviously this isn't what, you know, this is unacceptable for the writers of the Old Testament, the Tanakh. Because there's only one God. Because there is only one God. And the idea that an earthly king could become a son of God is shocking and scandalous. But they kind of work around it. And this again is what Dunstan seems to be drawing on with his order of service for Edgar, is this idea that becoming a son of God, becoming an anointed one, becoming a Christ for the Israelite kings is a process of service, that you are being pledged to serve as the son
他们变得神圣了。显然，这不是《旧约》（《塔纳赫》）的作者们所能接受的。因为只有一个神。因为只有一个神。而尘世的国王可以成为神的儿子的想法是令人震惊和骇人听闻的。但他们对此进行了变通。这再次体现了邓斯坦为埃德加设计仪式时所汲取的东西：成为神的儿子、成为受膏者、成为以色列诸王的基督，这一过程是一种服事的历程，意味着你发誓要作为神的儿子来服事。
of God. In other words, you're the servant of God and you're the servant of his people. And this is, again, a kind of incredibly potent idea. And obviously for Christians, this idea of an anointed king who is the servant of his people gets an extra kind of theological dimension because that is the role that Jesus comes to serve for Christians. So that idea of, say, David or Solomon as the servant of his people, in the Christian reworking of it in the New Testament, this provides the ultimate model for any Christian. And so in a way, kings are being anointed and enthroned as kind of Christian archetypes in that sense, which is why kings have to pledge themselves to be servants of their people.
换句话说，你是神的仆人，你是他子民的仆人。这也是一个具有极其强大力量的概念。显然，对于基督徒来说，这种受膏之王作为其子民仆人的理念具有了额外的神学维度，因为这就是耶稣为基督徒所履行的角色。因此，大卫或所罗门作为其子民仆人的理念，在《新约》对其进行的基督教改造中，为任何基督徒提供了最终的模范。因此在某种程度上，国王们被涂油并登基，在这个意义上成为了某种基督教原型，这就是为什么国王必须发誓成为他们子民的仆人。
Right. But the king is kind of the image of God, right? Or the vehicle of God's representative on earth to some extent. Is that fair? So that is something that changes and evolves over the course of time. Okay. Because the degree to which a coronation and anointing makes a king a sacral figure, the degree to which he can stand rank, say, with bishops or archbishops, the degree to which he is appointed directly by God, all of these have huge theological and therefore cultural implications for the peoples that he's ruling. And so these are things that have changed and evolved over the course of time. But I think the core idea, the idea that
没错。但国王在某种程度上是上帝的形象，对吧？或者在某种程度上是上帝在人间的代表的载体？这样说公平吗？这确实是随着时间推移而改变和演变的某些东西。好的。因为加冕礼和涂油礼使国王成为神圣人物的程度，他可以与主教或大主教平起平坐的程度，他直接由上帝任命的程度，所有这些都对他所统治的人民产生了巨大的神学和文化影响。因此，这些都是随着时间推移而改变和演变的事情。但我认为核心理念，即
an anointing in some way is a religious ritual that marks an individual ruler out as someone with a particular responsibility for the care of his people to God is something that is fabulously ancient. And the ritual that will happen on Saturday is basically the last surviving example of that. That still endures into 21st century. I think the same thing happens in Tonga, actually, but it is a kind of copy of the British ritual. Right. happens in Tonga, actually, but it is a kind of copy of the British ritual. So I think that that is a properly weird thing to be watching in the 21st century.
涂油在某种程度上是一个宗教仪式，它将个别统治者标榜为对上帝肩负着关爱子民特定责任的人，这是一个极其古老的理念。而周六将要发生的仪式基本上是这一理念最后幸存的例子。它一直延续到了21世纪。事实上，汤加也发生了同样的事情，我认为，但这只是对英国仪式的模仿。没错。事实上，汤加也发生了，但这基本上是英国仪式的复制。所以我认为，在21世纪观看这样一件事是相当诡异的。
But you're using weird in your special Tom Holland way. Yes, in the old English sense. The weird sisters. It's uncanny. You're not disapproving of the coronation, Tom. Otherwise, we'll have to have stern words. There are, of course, lots of people who would absolutely see it as weird. And I think that one of the interesting questions about what the impact of this coronation will be, will people be moved and impressed by this, this sense of a kind of very ancient sacred ritual? Or will they regard it as wholly grotesque and ludicrous and say, well, why are we doing this kind of mumbo jumbo in the 21st century? Well, for those people, all I say is France is only a short change only away, if that's your
但你是在用你那独特的汤姆·霍兰德方式使用“诡异”这个词。是的，在古英语的意义上。麦克白的三女巫。这太不可思议了。汤姆，你并不是在反对加冕典礼吧。否则我们就得严肃谈谈了。当然，有很多人绝对会认为这很诡异。我认为关于这场加冕典礼的影响会是什么，一个有趣的问题是：人们会被这种非常古老的神圣仪式的感觉所感动和打动吗？还是会认为它完全是荒诞滑稽的，并说，为什么我们在21世纪还要搞这种胡言乱语？好吧，对于那些人，我只能说，如果那是你的
answer. Listen, one of the many interesting things about it, Tom, that was absolutely fascinating, by the way, is the contrast between the dignity, the grandeur, the spiritual profundity of the ceremony, and the often absolutely ludicrous and preposterous characters who have played the central parts, right? I mean, George IV, Henry VIII, James I, Mary Elizabeth. There's some great characters there. And what we're going to do in the next two podcasts is to see how the sort of meaning, the tremendous spiritual meaning and significance, how it survives its encounter with historical reality. You know, horses going the wrong way, things collapsing, people getting drunk.
回答，去法国也就转个车的距离。听着，汤姆，其中许多有趣的事情之一，顺便说一句，绝对引人入胜的是，仪式的庄严、宏伟、精神深刻性，与那些在其中扮演核心角色的往往绝对荒谬和荒唐的人物之间形成了鲜明对比，对吧？我的意思是，乔治四世、亨利八世、詹姆斯一世、玛丽、伊丽莎白。那里有一些很棒的角色。我们接下来两个播客要做的是，看看那种精神上的巨大意义和重要性，如何在与历史现实的交锋中存活下来。（你知道的，马跑错了方向，东西倒塌了，人们喝醉了。）
People rolling down steps, eating sandwiches. Yeah, that's great. People getting bored during coronations and starting to have picnics. I don't think we'll see that on Saturday. So there are some traditions that we haven't kept up, Tom, which is a shame. So we will be back next time and we'll be beginning our great sweep through the history of coronations and the way in which they provide a window into different eras of English history. So Tom, thanks for the tour de force. And on that bombshell, we'll see you next time.
人们从台阶上滚下来，吃三明治。是的，太棒了。人们在加冕典礼期间感到厌烦并开始野餐。我想我们在周六不会看到这种情况。所以有些传统我们没有保留下来，汤姆，这真是个遗憾。所以我们下次会回来，我们将开始纵览加冕典礼的历史，以及它们为了解英国历史不同时期提供的一个窗口。汤姆，谢谢你的精彩演说。带着这个重磅炸弹，我们下次见。
Bye-bye. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's rest isistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史就是如此》（The Rest is History）。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restisistorypod.com 注册，网址是 restisistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。